حزن يلف تركيا
وتضامن مع ذوي الضحايا
وشارع الاستقلال يحاول النهوض مجددا بعد
الانفجار هذا هو المشهد الاخير في اسطنبول
بعد التفجير الذي خلف عشرات القتلى
والجرحى
تصادف وجود صاحب محل تصفيف الشعر هذا مع
موظفه في المحل لحظه التفجير
عده امطار فقط كانت تفصلهم عن مكان انفجار
القنبله ناجه جميعا لكن مشهد الشظايا
والهلع الذي عاشوه ما زال ماثلا امامهم
منذ الحادثه
من الدكان بعد الانفجار لدينا جريح واحدا
الان الحمد لله هو بساحه جيده كانت لدينا
اضرار لكن ستعودنا الدوله بالضبط
عند اول ما طلعت من الصالون طلعت هيك لبرا
العالم مشلفه يمين ويسار يعني اكثر منظر
للي هو اثر اللي كانت هون مرض فيهم مراه
عم تبكي كثير بتصيح انه بس انقذونا انا
وابني في زلمه مشطح قدام منك
كمان في مره كانت
اجره مضروبه
مرعبه ايضا هذا الشاب
تجري الكل يرقد في جميع الاتجاهات عند
نهوض شربت الماء ثم بدات سيارته
للبيت
من بينهم امراه سوريه
زراعه القنبله تحت احد المقاعد في شارع
الاستقلال
تركيا بطريقه السوريه
وفقا لطبيعه وتوقيت تفجير شارع الاستقلال
فانه لن يمر دون توظيفه في المشهد السياسي
التركي خصوصا مع قرب الانتخابات
البرلمانيه والرئاسيات المقبله من شارع
الاستقلال في اسطنبول زيدان زينجو العربيه